und zum schluss müssen wir auch da
einmal über friseure sprechen denn diese
dürfen jetzt bald wieder aufmachen man
muss tatsächlich sagen bisher war es
geteiltes leid ist halbes leid denn
natürlich warten viele deutsche
sehnsüchtig auf den nächsten
friseurbesuch manche haben jetzt in der
zwischenzeit auch schon selbst zur
schere oder dem haarschneider gegriffen
mit mal mehr mal weniger erfolg und so
geht es offenbar auch dem vizekanzler
olaf scholz wir uns heute hier bei bet
live verraten hat wie haben sie sich in
den vergangenen wochen um die sagen
können selbst und mal besser mal
schlechter
wenn also froh wenn ich wieder zum
friseur kann also sie haben tatsächlich
selbst den den rasierer angelegt ich
befürchte man sieht das auch ja es gibt
ein foto wo man es häufig sehen konnte
tatsächlich dass das einmal missglückt
war also da haben sie vieles gemeinsam
mit vielen anderen deutschen die das
auch versucht haben ja und wie ich
glaube wir haben alle schätzen gelernt
was für eine bedeutung friseure haben
selbst wenn man wenig haare hatte